[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages as they come in time to
see what's making those headlines with
the political editor at the daily mirror
pippa
and the political editor at the sun
harry cole great to see both of you and
of course you'll be with us until just
before midnight so to the front pages
then let us start with the telegraph it
leads with the kremlin's terms for a
peace deal moscow claims fighting could
be halted almost immediately if ukraine
agreed to its demands
the time says mr putin's plans are
clearly mapped on the faces of its
ukrainian victims
the guardian reports kiev has rejected
russia's offer to create humanitarian
corridors to allow civilians to flee
half a dozen heavily bombed ukrainian
cities
in the metro the ex-head of the army
lord danette insists the uk must welcome
more refugees the headline pull your
finger out
calls for the british government to help
more ukrainians is also the lead story
for the eye
the financial times reporting on world
markets being rattled over fluctuations
in oil and gas prices as countries argue
over whether to ban the purchase of
russian crude oil as part of sanctions
against moscow the delhi mayor leading
with the prime minister's plans for more
drilling in the north sea to help
stabilize energy prices
let it go the sun's message to the
russian leader of vladimir putin as a
young girl singing the popular disney
song from her bunker goes viral
and mocking international women's day
the sheffield star focuses on the women
and children facing an uncertain fate in
ukraine
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of those newspapers while you
watch us so let's bring in them peppa
crui and harry cole welcome to both of
you um pippa let's go straight to the
metro shall we pull your finger out the
thoughts of many no doubt about the uh
the visa situation for these refugees
with many asking why do you have visas
anyway uh ms patel
yes well we've reached the point now
where the united nations says that more
than 1.5 million ukrainians have fled
from
the war zone that is their country just
now and the majority of them have stayed
in the region obviously lots of them
only want to be there temporarily and to
be able to go home as soon as they
possibly can this is as soon as it's
safe so you're seeing a million people
currently in poland
uh 200 000 in hungary slightly less in
slovakia um but the british government
has said that it will step up and be as
generous as um as it possibly can be
with boris johnson and petey patel
saying on several occasions today that
that would be the case the problem is is
that offer of generosity doesn't seem to
be reflected yet in practice there was a
figure put out yesterday from the home
office that just 50 visas had been
issued to
ukrainian refugees to come to the uk
and the prime minister slapped down that
figure earlier and said no no absolutely
not that was completely wrong peter
patel did the same in the house of
commons later suggesting it would be a
much more generous number and we find
out tonight that actually 300 visas have
been issued not only that but the
promise of a
processing centre in calais that pretty
patel told the commons was already
initially told the commons it was really
set up and they then later had to admit
that in fact that hadn't already been
established and there's currently poster
in the windows of um of
the voter force in kelly suggesting that
people need to go to paris or brussels
and the home office has admitted tonight
that they were just going to be um
a hundred appointments set aside for
ukrainians in the paris
uh the paris consulate uh this week in
order to be able to apply to the uk so
the scale of the refugee crisis doesn't
really feel that it's been matched yet
by the british offer of generosity i
mean harry and i spoke about this last
week on on sky news and at that point we
said look the situation's so fast moving
it's only a couple of days let's give
them time to catch up here we are a
whole week on and they still don't seem
to be in a position where we're more
willing to open our doors to more people
who to desperately want to join their
families here
yes the home office update that we had
this evening suggested 17
700 ukraine family scheme applications
had been started
uh 8 900 had been submitted of which 300
visas have been issued so that's the the
rate they're getting through it so far
the eye also on this uh the uk edge to
help refugees out
escapees they say are trapped near
calais liz trust says pretty patel is
responsible for the plan
some being told to go back to poland
where there's uh visa help apparently
now um but this was easy to plan for
wasn't it is it you know how many months
of those russian troops been surrounding
uh
surrounding ukraine i mean you could you
could have worked this out
i think that's probably
a bit of a stretch i have to say because
there was actually if we cast our minds
back even
two weeks ago there was still a large as
a percent of
a large part of the government still was
hoping and doing everything they
possibly could to avoid the situation
all of our efforts diplomatically were
being put towards um being principals
trying to stop uh this invasion now look
it is an incredibly fast moving
situation and yes i do think we um we
could be going faster however you do
need to remember the vast vast vast
majority of people fleeing
from putin's terror do not necessarily
want to move to the united kingdom or
move to another european country they
want to go home as quickly as they
possibly can so i think we're slightly
forgetting that actually it's it's a
two-pronged approach in the fact that we
are doing a lot and a lot of financial
help to poland who are bearing the brunt
of this uh of this
horrific
outpouring of
of desperate people across their borders
and most of them want to stay in poland
because they want to go home
sooner rather than later rather move
here that's not to say that the people
that do want asylum here should be
helped quicker now there's a really
interesting row going on
behind the scenes because pretty patel
is obviously getting in the neck a lot
there's a suggestion she's this callous
evil woman who doesn't want to help
people but actually she went on the
record of the sun on sunday and said
actually i want to open up a
humanitarian route i want looking at the
legal options
to allow anyone any ukrainian citizen
even one who's not been
doesn't have family members here who is
not sponsored by an organization or a
group or a family to to come here i want
to to broaden that out and actually she
got slightly pillared and slapped down
for that today the foreign office were
very snooty about it and number 10 was
saying well
as this goes on we want to be as
generous as possible but we're not doing
that yet
so there is clearly a split in the
cabinet about how far it should go
and it's obviously you know having a
direct effect on
on on the policy implementation yeah
well who doesn't i mean harry who does
not want this to
be opened as a proper humanitarian
corridor then just quickly give us well
there seems to be there seems to be
fierce resistance to that there seems to
be the foreign officers saying actually
no you know james cleverley the foreign
office minister was out today saying no
we've got enough we're doing enough
we've already got these schemes up and
running and actually
uh
it's clearly not enough because there is
the the the demand is outstripping the
the amount of people who are able to
come so i do think they'll have to go
further and it seems that that sort of
tension about how they do it is spilling
over into public now
and and in terms of obviously people
want to go to nearby nations uh worth
bearing in mind that ireland has already
accepted 1800 ukrainian refugees of whom
486 arrived only yesterday so they're
going faster aren't they um pippa let's
move on to what needs to be done uh the
guardian uh and the telegraph as well
talking about this offer of putin to let
people first of all flee into russia and
bella russia
which obviously is not ideal for many of
them and al also this offer of moscow of
the parameters by which uh the action
the conflict could be ended immediately
they suggest which is also presumably
not acceptable to ukraine
well you say it's not ideal to many of
them but in fact it's the absolute
antithesis isn't it of anything that
they could hope for if they're trying to
flee their country why would they run
into the arms of the enemy as many of
them see it or it's probably what most
of them see it in russia or in belarus
running from you know a very sort of
volatile situation in ukraine into
potential stark danger for their lives
in enemy in enemy territory um it's a
deeply cynical offer uh vladimir um
vladimir putin who'd spoken to had
spoken to french president emmanuel
macron mike kronz absolutely slammed the
suggestion today
um as being completely unrealistic and
unhelpful but it's not the only
suggestion on the table from the
russians we've had the third round of
talks between russia and ukraine in an
attempt to try and reach some sort of
ceasefire the ukrainians have basically
said we've got one condition we want you
to remove troops from our territory
moscow however um has has other
conditions it's obviously with this
offer of the humanitarian corridors a
couple of which end up in ukrainian
territory but as we say um others not
but it also wants to um it wants ukraine
to cease all military action even though
it's defending its own territory it
wants to write neutrality into its
constitution so that it could never for
example end up joining nato and also
wants it not to join the european union
at any point as you'll know zalenski has
already in the past few days signed the
application to join the european union
and it wants crimea to be recognized as
part of of russia and the two annexed
provinces donetsk and
luhansk to be um recognized by ukraine
as independent nations now
on every level those uh you know pretty
much all of those demands are
unrealistic for ukraine so in a position
where it looks like more stalemate
between the two sides it's not a serious
offer from russia to try and get peace
and we're still left with the situation
of not knowing how this is going to play
out beyond the sort of the humanitarian
devastation of an ongoing war and just
we'll quickly see your paper we need to
get to the break harry um be your paper
of a little girl singing let it go from
her from her bunker
as we look ahead just very quickly to
vladimir zelinski who will give this
historic address to british mps tomorrow
yeah i suspect it could get quite spicy
actually i hope he gives him some a bit
of reality check on the situation on the
ground i expect he'll ask for a
for a no-fly zone and uh as as
both kia starmer and boris johnson have
made clear the political implications of
that the geopolitical implications of
that make it impossible but i suspect um
he won't hold back and nor should he
okay full coverage of that 5 p.m tuesday
stay there lots more still to come
including how can we show russia that we
don't need to rely on their gas anymore
that's been the suggestion back with
that after the break
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now as you can see
the political editor of the daily mirror
pippa crearer and the political editor
of the sun harry cole welcome back to
both of you um so to the daily mail
harry let's go to that the new dash for
gas this is uh boss johnson's
announcement today that he will be
revealing an energy supply strategy uh
which it would appear would give a
license for more drilling in the north
sea
absolutely prime minister would stay up
with trudeau and the his counterpart for
the netherlands today and
it made quite a passionate plea actually
to say look things that you couldn't
imagine possibly happening
weeks or even months ago we're going to
have to consider and very much on the
table now
is a ban on russian uh russian oil uh
crude oil now that's gonna send energy
markets uh around the world uh around
the bend which you did today record
prices at the pumps one pound fifty five
a liter and that's only going to go up
at this rate um gas prices soaring off
the charts not seen for 10 15 years
so worrying times the prime minister
made very clear that a new this new
energy strategy is gonna have to look at
the fact that yes we made lots of
commitments uh for net zero um yes we've
got all these green goals over the next
couple of decades but he basically said
it's a reality check here there's a
crunch there's gonna be a transition as
we move away from russian gas sorry
russian oil russian oil and gas and
dependency we have on that while we try
to boost our domestic markets our
domestic extraction and it's going to
hurt in in the meantime so
trying to start to level with the public
but
you wonder
how much public sympathy there's going
to be when you know people are filling
up their car and it's crippling you know
you saw what happened in that in that
sort of mini almost fake news field
crisis um back in october where there's
a panic buying managed to
empty petrol stations you saw how
quickly the country ground to the halt
and supply chains um were affected that
could very easily happen if people are
priced out of filling up their cars and
the pressure tonight we're launching a
campaign in the sun tomorrow to have
fuel duty cut by five pence now the
government frozen that for 12 years on
the back of our campaigns at every
single budget so far but there's a mini
budget
at the end of this month and not only us
rac others mps are saying it's time to
actually cut the duty on that because 57
pence of every liter goes to the
treasury yeah it's a it's a big number
you've only got 30 seconds your thoughts
on on what needs to be done pepper
well i think the reality is that it's
not just at the pumps but also people's
gas bills we're ready with the cost of
living crisis expected to store above
2000 pounds from april for the average
average gas bill and it's now looking as
though they could soar beyond 3000 4000
and come october when the price gap gets
lifted again as a result of the crisis
in ukraine that is going to hit people
incredibly hard so the chancellor is
going to have to do something at the
budget whether that's cutting vat
whether that's cutting fuel duty or
whether that's extra specific targeted
support that those that need it most
will have to wait and see but it is
inconceivable we will do something to
make it easier for people in the months
ahead pippa harry thank you both very
much indeed thank you they're with us
right through the 11 right now the
weather